yeah on myself and my friends it's just
a Halloween tradition here in Brooklyn
yes
a woman with shaving cream on her car
they're having a good time could have
been worse could have been eggs eggs
what are you gonna do with eggs good
guys
I'm gonna hit this kid over here
they put the eggs away because look at
this down the block a constable on
patrol in the mood to confiscate let me
have it come on we have it come on he
finally did hand it over as for the rest
they wrapped up their Halloween on the
Run New York police say they will be out
in force to make sure no one violates
the spirit of Halloween or the law will
spends Channel 7 Eyewitness News well
Halloween and trick-or-treating can be
fun
what's up everybody I'm Dave Rubin this
is the Reuben report it is November 1st
2022 and yes yesterday was Halloween I
hope you had a happy Halloween we took
the boys out in skeleton costumes and
although they cannot eat solid food yet
we got a bag of Kit Kats and Reese's
Peanut Butter Cups downstairs for one
day when they can that cold open I had
to just put that in that was
1984 New York City those kids looked
about eight years old I was born in 76
so I was about eight years old at that
point 1984. and it was just such a
perfect time capsule of how different
things were and how how much better
things were the idea that these kids
were running around in New York City and
they're kind of messing around with the
cops and yeah you might get some shaving
cream on your car but at least it's not
eggs as that lady says and that kid when
the when the reporter says what are you
gonna do with the eggs we're gonna cook
dinner
like the accent it's just so perfect and
it's it's so emblematic of a simpler
time and what I'm always telling you
guys like what are we really trying to
do politically in the world right now I
think we're just trying to go back to
that I think
that if the Gen X people the
eight-year-olds in 84 who are now you
know somewhere in their 40s can take the
reins of this thing whether it's a guy
like Elon Musk or whether it's a guy
like Joe Rogan or a guy like me or a guy
like you watching this if you're in that
sort of 35 to maybe late 50s thing that
Gen X thing it's like it's our time to
kind of take over we grew up in a time
when things were better and safer and
more decent and nobody cared about the
race stuff and we weren't interested in
chopping children's genitals off
it was the good old days people that's
the point uh but there is a lot to talk
about because one week from today is
election day and it's looking real good
but as I always say
let's not count the chickens before they
hatch uh you know you got to give the
devil his due and they can pull out some
kind of crazy tricks we're going to get
into some of their tricks they're
busting out Obama again I don't think
it's gonna work he seems a little rusty
if you ask me we got a bunch of Clips uh
and then really the big story yesterday
was that there has been a massive expose
that basically what we all thought was
happening
for quite some time that I've been
hinting at if not outright saying and
many of us those of us that exist in the
online world that there has been massive
coordination with the government uh and
big Tech in suppressing your speech when
it came to misinformation and covert
related things and all that a whole
bunch of documents have been leaked and
text messages and all sorts of stuff
um and this could be in in a real sense
a massive massive Scandal so we'll see
how the media tries to cover it up uh
also my buddy and a man that I know you
love if you're watching this show Larry
Elder might be running for president
like it's real he's been kind of telling
me for months now almost almost a year
actually since uh since the recall did
not work out the way he wanted he kind
of had bigger plans ready to roll and
Larry's been thinking about it for quite
some time so that's actually where we're
gonna start today uh because Newsweek
ran a piece yesterday about a potential
essential Larry Elder for president
candidacy but Larry put out a video
yesterday as well uh kind of given his
vision and what he's been up to and well
take a look we are at the faith and
freedom Coalition here in Charlotte
North Carolina well I had a really good
time I was sandwiched between two
Dynamic speakers but I talked about the
issues that affect America I talked
about the breakdown of the family which
in my opinion our side has not spend
enough time talking about we talk about
crime talk about poor schools talk about
people that are not ready to get jobs in
our digital economy we're really good
with the symptoms we're not that good
with the cause and we need to talk more
and more and more about what's happened
to the nuclear impact family and we got
to take this country back we got to take
back the house take back the Senate so
go to elderfloramerica.com throw a
little something in the tip jar because
we've got a country to say
the black face of white supremacy
according to the Los Angeles Times uh
look obviously the recall in California
did not go well Larry actually got
millions of votes and did way better
than most people thought but for
whatever reason be it the Sun or what's
going on in wine country or whatever
California just stuck it out with Gavin
Newsom okay the Machinery the Democrat
Machinery there is it is it is strong
whether we like it or not but Larry has
his eyes I sense on something much
bigger at this point and whether he can
become president or not
um I would argue is actually irrelevant
the message that Larry has been talking
about for years what the Democrats have
done to the black family the re the
reality related to systemic racism uh
these these ideas are things that he's
been the master at teaching American
Americans and I think it's incredible
that he's even thinking about it so
Newsweek wrote a piece on it it sounds
like it's going to happen talk radio
co-host and filmmaker Larry Elder's
political Ambitions have turned
presidential and he has a staff of
advisors preparing a possible run at the
Republican nomination for a man once
accused of being the black face of white
supremacy he told Newsweek that his
decision to run for the presidential
nomination would have nothing to do with
whether former president Donald Trump
runs again and was more about drawing
attention to what he says in an is an
underappreciated problem in America
fatherlessness crime spending inflation
the war on oil and gas the overrun
borders of course I want to discuss that
but also what's not talked about
the destruction of the nuclear intact
family Elder said in the 45-minute
interview women are incentivized to
marry the government and men are
incentivized to abandon their financial
responsibilities and that's led to 70
percent of black kids entering a world
without a father married to a mother
while it was 25 in 1965. so look guys
whether whether Larry has true Ambitions
to become the president or whether he
wants to get in the mix and get on that
debate stage so that he can spread the
message that he has been spreading for
basically almost four decades in the
public eye uh this is really really good
more and more good people getting
involved whether it's hey guys like Elon
Musk buying things like Twitter to fix
things or guys like Larry Elder getting
out of the radio game that he's been in
forever now moving on to the digital
Frontier where he's doing a show and
then saying hey and I'm also going to
throw my hat in the ring and run for
president this is good and it reminded
me a little bit I thought this is a
little throwback for you this is a
little over a year ago this is one of
the events that I opened for Larry Elder
for this was a little north of Los
Angeles and the reason I'm showing it to
you it's about a minute long is because
it was there was such a fun atmosphere
there they were calling him the
blackface of white supremacy you'll see
all the people in the crowd because they
kind of digged him and it didn't matter
what color their skin was and it didn't
matter what gender they were sexuality
or rest of it but there was like
American flags and a joy and and it did
not work out in Cali but maybe there was
something being seated at that time that
could go National so this is about a
year ago me and Larry Elder
nobody is sweating like gather Newsom
right this very moment
[Music]
Maxwell where are you I'm hanging with
your mom at the Larry Elder rally great
lady by the way really fantastic
foreign
[Music]
Newsome is tweeting this and he's
bringing in his spectacularly loved uh
surrogates like Elizabeth Warren and Amy
Klobuchar yeah he brought in a fake
Native American from Boston to tell us
how we should live okay
and what they're afraid of is that Larry
Elder from the hood went to a public
school will be able to make the case the
black and brown people you are being
betrayed
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
anyway the point of all that guys is to
show you that good people are getting
involved and there is something so good
in America and we we let it go for too
long but we're about to grab it back and
I think that is incredibly exciting it
should it should be lighting a fire in
you these these final seven days before
this election like we have a chance
whether it is to get back to that cold
open with those kids in 1984 where
shaving cream in New York City was the
biggest issue with the cops as opposed
to now where your you know Grandma's
being pushed in front of the Subway or
the post-racial world that most of us
live in that Larry Elder has been
fighting for for so long but the woke
and the Democrats have tried to uh
completely reverse it's like we can
really get it back and we can get to
something that was something we had and
we didn't know how precious it was uh I
am going to contrast Larry Elder in his
message uh with former president Barack
Obama in just a moment but let me talk
to you guys a little bit about what the
blaze is doing for election night you
know election night is just around the
corner and the stakes have never been
higher for the midterms in case that
isn't clear several races across the
country have gotten very interesting in
the past couple weeks will the
Republicans be able to win a senate seat
in Washington state of all places is
Kathy hochel really in trouble in New
York yes will voters punish Gretchen
Whitmer for her coveted lockdown
insanity and finally give her the boot I
hope so there's a ton to cover this
election cycle and we've got you covered
Stu bergier who kind of serves as the
blaze media's resident
physiologist is that a word uh that's
just a fancy word that means someone who
studies elections put together a
comprehensive guide to let you know
exactly what you need to look for on
Election night head over to theblaze.com
election guide to receive a free copy of
the blaze media's Ultimate Guide to the
midterms delivered to your inbox again
that's theblaze.com election guide and
we will send you everything you need to
know to be ready for the big election
night and now back to me and yes I think
it is going to be a good night and I
will present evidence over the course of
the next 45 minutes to prove it anyway
let's compare and contrast Larry Elder
you know what Larry Elder believes
he believes in Freedom he believes in
limited government he thinks America is
pretty good that kind of stuff he
doesn't believe in neo-racism uh and
then there is former president Barack
Obama now Barack Obama's been pretty
quiet over the past couple years and I
will give him credit for that there were
moments that he stepped in some things
but you know usually ex-presidents they
kind of get out of the way whether they
agree or disagree with the guy that
follows them they usually get out of the
way sometimes they they come back when
there's National emergencies right when
Bill Clinton and George W bush came back
together after Hurricane Katrina like
there's some moments of that or when you
know a Statesman usually from another
country uh passes away they show up at
funerals that sort of thing so he's
mostly been away but they're busting him
out this week big time so they got him
somehow he left his 30-acre Oceanfront
mansion in Martha's Vineyard where by
the way they have no illegal immigrants
because they cannot have them in
Martha's Vineyard they can have them in
Texas border towns but no no no not
those good Democrats of Martha's
Vineyard anyway they busting out Obama
to campaign for some of these Democrats
because they realize it's going to be
bad and he that's the kitchen sink Obama
is the kitchen sink remember hope and
change man it's like if hope and change
man can't save us we're really really
screwed so Obama's given a bunch of
rallies uh here's a little video
like it just happened
just last year
is it like the the previous president
wasn't there
and by the way it didn't just happen in
so-called blue States
turns out has gone up in conservative
rural states too
where Republicans in charge but they
they don't mention that in the ads
so here's the question who will fight to
keep you and your family safe
he was supposed to be hope and change
and really all he turned out to be was
more of the same it is so true he is so
deeply disingenuous so first off he's
being very glib about crime in general
right because it's he knows that the
Democrats are basically in charge of
everything right now so there's a
glibness to it like oh they're focusing
on crime as if we shouldn't think about
crime right and we shouldn't worry about
that now first he's also mentioning that
it's Republican states that have some of
this crime now that is true of course
but all top 10 cities where crime is the
highest right now where murder rates are
up and and larceny and all of the bad
stuff rape and general Mayhem they're
all democrat-run cities you guys know it
everyone knows it New York City San
Francisco Portland Seattle the list goes
on and on what he of course also left
out there is when he's saying well they
forget about uh the the my predecessor
and what was going on with him uh yeah
it was Democrats and antifa and BLM the
base of the Democrat Party that was
burning down the cities right it was
your is Obama it was the guys who vote
and support for you uh for you right
like that is it's just true and it's
obvious and we all know that crime is
way up under Biden than it ever was
under trump it is absolutely true I'm
actually getting some info here on the
Fly uh from Phoenix of the top 25
highest crime cities in the United
States only one has a Republican mayor
that happens to be Jacksonville Florida
so the other 24 of 25 are democrat-run
cities is there a connection between say
Democrat policies and crime do you think
that might be something that we should
look into yeah uh and you guys know it
like you you just absolutely know it uh
anyway he was that was a rally in
Michigan he continued to give a very
strange defense of Gretchen Whitmer
because she's in a lot of trouble right
now Tudor Dixon is is picking up a lot
of steam we showed you some videos from
the debate uh Whitmer she was one of the
biggest proponents of lockdowns she
literally banned people from gardening
in their backyards you may remember that
we sent I sent a whole bunch of people
in Michigan seeds so that they could
plant things because they could not buy
them in areas around Detroit so Obama
somehow figured out a way to defend
Gretchen Whitmer
wild crazy talk
you just want somebody's doing their job
that's what governor Whitmer is focused
on I mean imagine if if you know you
hire your plumber you gotta you gotta
overflowing toilet it's a problem
he comes in
and you know you're waiting for the
toilet to be fixed he said have you
heard
about
[Music]
the latest conspiracy of the lizard
people and he starts talking to me about
all this stuff we got to do something
about that you'd be like no no no I I
just want you to fix my toilet
isn't it true like the hope and change
thing how he just became he's just more
of the same that's all that he is what
what plumbers are showing up to
somebody's house in Michigan and talking
about lizard people instead of doing
their jobs now if you mean that
Republicans generally have jobs and go
ahead and do the things that a lot of
your supporters don't want to do like
maybe being a plumber I guess you're
probably right on that
um Gretchen Whitmer was just doing her
job just doing her job when she was
shutting down the state just doing her
job when she told people they couldn't
get on boats and she jumped on her
family boat for her her husband's
birthday party without masks like what
are you talking about so Obama is just
one of them that is all he is at this
point now I get it he's pulling the
strings on the on the Biden machine too
but man what a disappointment he turned
out to be fortunately not everybody in
the crowd was loving Barack Obama and
when he's not reading off the
teleprompter you know he's quite a good
orator right I'll give him credit on
that but when he gets off that prompter
he definitely struggles and the crowd
was not having it well at least some
people in the crowd were not having it
right now I'm talking
[Applause]
it's not a good way to do business it's
that you wouldn't do that in a workplace
if you wouldn't just interrupt people in
the middle of a conversation it's not
how we do things
and this is part of the point that I
want to make
just basic civility
and courtesy works and that's what we
want to try to encourage
so listen that's okay no no no no no
wait wait wait wait Squad down fly down
look eight lessons hey
hold up hold up
hold up hold up hold on a minute
[Applause]
this is listen everybody hey
y'all up there pay attention
here's what happens listen
I mean he was really losing control of
that thing and you know he goes into
that fake accent and he does all his
very you can see there like trained
coordinated moves to kind of look cool
and everything look I'm not for for
people coming in and shouting down
speakers right it has happened to me
many many times but when Obama's up
there this is a conversation you'll get
your chance to talk no it isn't it it's
a lecture you're not there to Obama's
gonna like walk out after like where's
that guy who had that issue to spew I
I'd like to talk to him like come on
come on but I I just really think people
are not buying it anymore there's this
he's able to do because he is again a
skilled auditor he's able to do this
folksy thing that makes it seem like
he's the good guy so that's what he's
doing there like that guy's the bad guy
because he's yelling down and we just
need we just need more civility except
he's the same person from the same party
that runs around calling half the
country Nazis and racists and he's gone
all in on the woke stuff so it's like if
you're if you're doing that and
demonizing half the country but you do
it civilly because you know your shirt's
tucked in nice and and you got nice
teeth and your body language is kind of
good it's like no we can kind of see
through that and by the way we can also
see through the rest of the nonsense
that Obama's been pushing for a long
time this is a video and this is going
to link us to the theme for the rest of
the show this is a video back in April
of 2022 so this year this is only about
six months ago where Barack Obama
was in essence calling for social media
censorship that the Democrats are losing
the narrative and yeah we better stop
those lizard people it does still nag at
me though
was my failure to fully appreciate at
the time
just how susceptible we had become
to lies
and conspiracy theories
despite having spent years being a
target of disinformation myself social
media companies already make choices
about what is or is not allowed on their
platforms and how that content appears
both explicitly through content
moderation and implicitly through
algorithms
the problem is we often don't know what
principles govern those decisions in
some cases industry standards may
replace or substitute for regulation but
regulation has to be part of the answer
beyond that
tech companies need to be more
transparent about how they operate as
Citizens we have to take it upon
ourselves
to become better consumers of news
looking at sources thinking before we
share and teaching our kids to become
critical thinkers who know how to
evaluate sources and separate opinion
from fact
all right I get it you show that to the
average person and it all kind of sounds
right we want to watch out for
misinformation but it's his party his
corporate news his big tech people who
have been the main suppressors of
information that didn't go with the
narrative right
um it is his people that have been
coordinating we've got evidence of it
with big Tech to silence people and this
is the problem so the major story that
dropped yesterday and just let's just
see how the corporate media covers or
does not cover this one is that in
essence the FBI and the CIA have been
working with big Tech we all kind of
suspected it but yeah it turns out that
it's true we've got some info from
Breitbart here Executives from Facebook
and Twitter including the recently fired
head of trust and safety Vijaya Gotti
that was the woman who was just fired
from Twitter held regular meetings with
the Department of Homeland Security to
discuss censorship on a wide range of
topics including the withdrawal from
Afghanistan coronavirus and racial
Justice according to leaked documents
the information came to light via leaks
to The Intercept as well as documents
and minutes revealed through Missouri
Attorney General Eric admits lawsuit
filed against the Biden Administration
that alleges government collusion with
big Tech to suppress America's first
right First Amendment rights the report
also reveals
an official process for the government
to flag misinformation to Facebook via
The Intercept there is also a formalized
process for government officials to
directly flag content on Facebook or
Instagram and request that it be
throttled or suspended through a special
Facebook portal that requires a
government or law enforcement email to
use at the time of writing the content
request system at facebook.com X
takedowns slash login is still live DHS
Department of Homeland Security and meta
the parent company of Facebook did not
respond to a request for comment the FBI
declined to comment some of the meetings
between social media representatives and
the government included Kate starberg
the leftist professor who leads the
election Integrity partnership in June
the same DHS advisory committee of sisa
which includes Twitter head of legal
policy trust and safety Vijaya got a and
University of Washington Professor Kate
star drafted a report to the sisa
director calling for an expansive role
for the agency in shaping the
information ecosystem the report called
on the agency to closely monitor social
media platforms of all sizes mainstream
media cable news hyper partisan media
talk radio and other online resources
they argued that the agency needed to
take steps to Halt the spread of false
and misleading information with a focus
on information that undermines key
Democratic institutions such as the
courts or by other sectors such as the
financial system or public health
measures okay guys this is seriously
massive this is not nothing this is big
okay the government was working with big
Tech we all kind of thought it it all
felt very weird why did that Hunter
Biden thing disappear why could people
not only not share the story and the New
York Post a place of Journalism for over
a hundred years was suspended from
Twitter but if you took the link from
their website and shared it in your
private messages on Twitter your direct
messages suddenly it would disappear
why is it that we know obviously some
people are blown off Twitter
they're blown off Twitter like Donald
Trump like project Veritas because they
go against the narrative and it very
rarely happens to lefties the idea that
the government wasn't even just about
covet and elections it was also about
people who were arguing against the
narrative related to Afghanistan I mean
this is deep deep stuff and really think
about it what is the first amendment
guys you all know it I have a bright
audience right this is an MSNBC over
here the First Amendment means that the
government cannot infringe on your right
to free speech so if you were using your
speech on a platform like Twitter and
the government was coming in and
censoring it Shadow Banning it deleting
it whatever they were doing with it a
government agent was acting and
infringing on your First Amendment right
to free speech this is this is huge like
huge huge huge here's a journalist over
at The Intercept who's got a bit more
his name's Lee Fang the emails and
documents show close collaboration
between Department of Homeland Security
and private sector Twitter's Vijaya got
a fired by Elon Musk last week met
monthly with Department of Homeland
Security to discuss censorship plans
Microsoft exec texted Department of
Homeland Security platforms have got to
get comfortable with government and then
here it goes into the text right here
thanks so much really appreciate it and
sorry I didn't ring last week think you
were on a call this week just trying to
get us a place get us in a place where
the FED can work with platforms to
better understand the mid
disinfo Trends so relevant agencies can
try to pre-bunk debunk as useful not our
mission but was looking to a coordinated
role so not every D.A is independently
reaching out to platforms which would
cause a lot of chaos was on the call the
coordination is greatly appreciated was
disappointed that platforms including us
didn't offer more will get there and
sector leadership had zero questions
we'll get there and that kind of
leadership really helps platforms have
got to get more comfortable with
government it's really interesting how
hesitant they remain again Microsoft
included this is the woman who is in
charge of trust and safety at Twitter
the very same woman who Elon Musk fired
this week who is going to really try to
get her golden parachute which could be
like 20 million bucks but he's saying he
fired her for cause
she is the one that is personally
personally responsible for booting Trump
off Twitter there she is texting about
how she wants more government
coordination and what else can they do
so the government and big Tech was
working in cahoots to silence you but
not just you me remember this tweet I
keep showing you this one and I had a
feeling something weird was going on
with it way back when this was me back
in July of 2021 not this July a year ago
July they want a federal vaccine mandate
for vaccines which are clearly not
working as promised just weeks ago
people are getting and transmitting
covid despite the facts plus now they're
prepping us for booster shots a sane
society would take pause we do not live
in a sane Society everything I said in
that tweet in July of 2021 was true
vaccines were not working as promised
they were clearly pushing us towards
boosters and mandates were coming that
got me suspended from Twitter so the
question is and I do this all the time
this is not to make this about me but it
is a perfect example of what the high
hell is going on here between the
government and big Tech did Twitter
Vijaya got a and whoever her minions
were at Twitter did they independently
decide that that tweet was
misinformation or it was scary or
disinformation or whatever it might be
and they as a as a company decided to
take it down or were they contacted by
the government it sounds very possible
that it was the government they had this
Secret login we know they were doing all
this coordination did someone from the
government say that well Reuben just uh
leaked out what we all know to be true
but it's a little early for the truth to
get out there we can't just have the
truth getting out there in real time you
got to take this thing down in which
case My First Amendment rights were
violated I don't know I actually
contacted a couple lawyers this morning
like I would love to know what actually
is the recourse if your first amendment
rights are violated meaning it's like
I'm not interested in doing this this
isn't the point but like can you sue
Twitter can you sue the government I
mean certainly it seems like some people
from the government would have to step
down if your job is to defend the
Constitution of the United States and
you do something that is in direct
violation of the Constitution and the
Bill of Rights you got a problem on your
hand and by the way again guys and this
is what why something is so cool uh
something so cool is happening right now
a lot of us have been talking about all
of this for a long time a lot of us have
been talking about how no one really was
was into the woke and it all felt fake
and none of this made any sense but now
it's becoming obvious that it was all
true uh and Senator Ted Cruz I think has
been one of the leaders on this from uh
from a governmental perspective uh here
he is this is uh what is this about a
year and a half ago uh Senator Ted Cruz
asking then Twitter CEO Jack Dorsey he
has since stepped down why the New York
Post story about Hunter Biden was
censored why did Twitter make the
decision to censor the New York Post
uh we had a hack materials policy
um when was that policy adopted uh in
2018 I believe in 2018 go ahead what was
what was the policy so the policy is
around
um limiting the spread of materials uh
that are hacked
um we didn't want Twitter to be a
distributor for hack materials
um we found that the near post because
it showed the direct materials
screenshots of the direct materials and
it was unclear how those were attained
that it felt that it fell under this
policy now so in your view if it's
unclear the source of of a document in
this instance the New York Post
documented what it said the source was
which it said it was a laptop owned by
Hunter Biden that had been turned into a
repair store
so they weren't hiding what they claimed
to be the swords
is it is it your position that Twitter
when you can't tell the source blocks
blocks press stories
no not at all
um we our team made a fast decision uh
the enforcement action however of
blocking URLs both in tweets and uh in
DM in direct messages we believe was
incorrect
okay so at the end there we believe it
was incorrect what we did yeah a year
and a half later after Biden got elected
and all that uh Cruz did a great great
job there because it is very clear that
the Biden laptop was not hacked hacked
would have been that that Hunter Biden
would have been snort would you snort
crack or do you smoke crack I guess I
guess you smoke crack he would have been
smoking crack and on his porn websites
and he would have been doing his thing
you know doing this or I guess it would
have been one-handed he would have been
doing his thing and then some hackers
would have broke into his Wi-Fi or
whatever and stolen the information as
Ted Cruz lays out there that we know
that's not the case and it was known
from day one Hunter Biden literally
brought the laptop to the repair shop so
there was no hack there was no hack uh
so so the question really for Jack
Dorsey and again he does not work at
Twitter anymore and maybe he wisely
stepped down knowing that a shitstorm
wasn't coming uh is hey who actually led
to this decision did you get a call all
did someone from the government
log into a special account that they
have you know a special place where they
set up so that government officials are
able to contact people at Facebook and
Twitter and everything else to get rid
of certain stories to admit two years
later after you got the results of the
election that you wanted that oh maybe
we kind of screwed up that ain't good
enough but that being said Elon Musk is
now in charge of Twitter and I think
we'll expose a lot of this nonsense and
Jack Dorsey is long gone the other
interesting thing about all of this is
that they've been doing it right in
front of our faces how many times have I
shown you guys this video this is Jen
saki when she was White House Press
Secretary again this is July of 2021
right around I think this was within a
week of when I sent out that tweet that
I was suspended for this is jensaki
admitting that the White House
coordinates with big Tech to silence you
this is a big issue of misinformation
specifically on the pandemic in terms of
actions Alex that we have taken or we're
working to take I should say from the
federal government
we've increased disinformation research
and tracking within the surgeon
general's office we're flagging
problematic posts for Facebook that
spread disinformation
lagging problematic posts the government
is saying to Big Tech hey we don't like
this like uh here's a guy that says
maybe the vaccine doesn't work we can't
have people saying that we flag it now
the interesting use of the word flag the
implication is we didn't force them to
do anything but imagine first off this
was before obviously this new
information was exposed where they are
coordinating together and they're
admitting it but even putting that aside
if the government is constantly calling
you as a business owner and being like
you're doing something a little bit
wrong there do you think you might start
doing something a little bit differently
and then perhaps that would be a
violation of your First Amendment right
the government could kind of keep
calling you up being like you know we
don't like what you're doing there when
you're selling those shoes that way
we're not big fans of that we're not
telling you not to do it but you know we
just want you to know we're not fans
sort of like they could call a tech
company and be like you know we're not
telling you to take these things down uh
but you know we're just letting you know
we're watching and uh you know we happen
to be the guys that are in charge of
breaking up companies and we look into
taxing people and auditing people you
think that maybe there's something there
yeah I think there's maybe something
there uh anyway uh the clown show like
the televised mental institution MSNBC
they are freaking out right now because
as more of this gets exposed their
nonsense and their corporate
coordination with big Tech and the
Democrats to silence you and confuse you
when it came to truth and honesty and
reality related to covet and so much
more that is crumbling in front of their
eyes right now so what do they have to
do they have to make sure that you think
that Elon and Twitter is a violent
attack on Democracy on pizzagate cabal
style stuff the idea that the world is
secretly run by this new world order uh
and it is trying to censor you it's
trying to prevent the world from seeing
what's really going on and that Nancy
Pelosi and people like that those people
uh in the Q Anon spaces right now those
people are at the top of that sphere
they are at the top of that pecking
order when it comes to how people
believe in conspiracy theories and I do
want to stress this first of all lies on
the internet move faster than the truth
and that's in part why they're all these
safeguards that Elon Musk is trying to
take down on Twitter right now there was
this World building on the pro-trump
internet what could be the opposite of
reality here
in the opposite reality they came up
with was these two people were having a
Lover's Coral in a house and the police
sort of intruded on us
it's fundamentally incorrect was pushed
by the richest man in the world and then
yesterday it was pushed by Donald Trump
Jr who posted a picture of underwear and
a hammer and said it's a Halloween
costume for Paul Pelosi
if we don't cut this out right now not
just the normalization of violence but
the idea that reality can't even exist
anymore because it cannot catch up to
the lies on the internet
I'm not a scholar on authoritarian
history but I've read Hannah rent I've
read all of these people
this is how it gets really bad
this is the start of something that gets
really really bad if you are getting the
guardrails off the truth where it
literally cannot catch up to the lies on
the internet because of how the pipes
work how the system works because of the
incentives of the richest people in the
world
then that's how you lose your democracy
guys
this guy's freaking out about losing
democracy because of Q Anon and what
people are saying online well there's a
guy by the name of Kyle Becker Dad we
had Kyle on the show I think maybe we
had him on one Friday panel once we
should get them back on he's an actual
journalist he does a great job of
exposing media nonsense that's what he's
mostly focused on and right before the
show today I saw he tweeted out a list
of conspiracy theories that the
mainstream media pushed so here you have
this guy that that guy by the way Ben
Collins there his his title at NBC News
is he's on the dystopian beat he's
always looking for misinformation he's
one of the biggest Peddlers of
misinformation uh that exists right
because he's just doing it he has a
corporate desk so whatever he says his
misinformation is misinformation so
anyway Kyle Becker put out this awesome
list and here are some mainstream media
hoaxes that these people sitting at that
desk that MSNBC and the view and CNN and
Washington posted a whole bunch more put
out there you tell me how many of these
turned out to be true this is this is
fantastic Russia collusion Trump called
Neo Nazis find people Jesse Smollett
Bubba Wallace garage poll the Covington
kids were racist Governor whitnap
Whitmer kidnapping plot Kavanaugh was a
rapist Trump P tape covid lab leak was a
conspiracy theory border agents whipped
migrants Trump saved nuclear secrets at
Mar-A-Lago the Steele dossier Russian
bounties on U.S soldiers in Afghanistan
Trump said drinking bleach would fight
covid Muslim travel ban Hunter Biden's
laptop was rushing disinformation Andrew
Cuomo was the best coveted leader Trump
built cages for migrant kids suleimani
the Iranian General was an austere
religious scholar Trump overfed koi fish
in Japan that was a good one remember
when he dumped the thing uh Bill Bill
back better will pay for itself Trump
tax cuts benefited only the rich cloth
masks prevent kovid if you get
vaccinated you won't catch kovid an SUV
killed parade Marchers as opposed to the
guy who's driving it Trump used tear gas
to clear a crowd for a Bible photo don't
say gay was in a bill Putin price hike
Ivermectin is a horse dewormer and not
for humans ends mostly peaceful
protesters Trump overpowered secret
service for the wheel of the Beast that
was a good one officer officer signic
was murdered by protesters on January 6
January 6 was an Insurrection Trump
mocked a reporter's disability and BYU
students rolled racist insults at Duke
volleyball player this is just a quick
list he put up together today good work
Kyle Becker these are the people that
have spread all of this nonsense and
misinformation and then they have
coordinated as we have all pushed back
on it and going something in reality is
not matching up with what we're seeing
online and in the news then they went
ahead and they tried to make sure that
enough of us would be Shadow banned and
censored into Oblivion but something
ain't working anymore so let's go back
to Crime misinformation and conspiracy
theories leading into this election
because that's what this is all about at
this point that's why it feels like
things are being ramped up like crazy uh
here is New York governor who nobody
voted for Kathy hochel uh saying that
it's Republicans who are just somehow
using propaganda to make you think
you're not safe in Democratic states
governale these are Master manipulators
they have this conspiracy going all
across America to try and convince
people that in Democratic states they're
not as safe well guess what they're also
not only election deniers they're data
deniers the data shows that shootings
and murders are down in our state by 15
percent even in New York City down 20
percent on Long Island really zeldin
comes from unbelievable they lie right
to your face but again this is one where
I would say to you guys you don't always
need the stats and the polls to show
everything we can read you I mean we've
done it a million times talking about
the crime and democrat-run cities
how about you just go to one of those
cities go to New York City as I did
about a month ago and it is not New York
City of old it is not it does not feel
safe it does not feel safe when you see
people being pushed not to Subways that
the cops know that they're not going to
be backed up so then we have all these
cops retiring and then unqualified
people that are becoming cops because
they just have to take anyone to be a
cop I mean there are huge huge problems
in democrat-run cities but she she's a
liar who is spending too much time
getting Botox and not enough time
actually trying to solve problems but
here's another one here's a gem there's
a gem of a woman for you Lori Lightfoot
the mayor of Chicago that was Halloween
yesterday so it's worth showing you Lori
Lightfoot video enjoy I'm there
um you introduced a measure today that
would change the way both the mayor the
city clerk and the City Treasurer get
pay raises capping them annually at five
percent
um why the change there and um why is
that a good use of City funds well to be
clear the ordinance that was introduced
today would put the mayor the city
treasurer and the clerk in line with all
the other elected officials regarding a
cost of living increase it's not a
salary increase I want to make sure
that's clear
man
I sometimes admire their ability to lie
it's not that I want to lie but it's
like it's a skill in and of itself it's
an evil devilish skill but it is a skill
did he catch what happened there she in
the midst of everything that is going on
in Chicago can I get the numbers on the
amount of people shot and killed in
Chicago this weekend please
um which you will not hear about on
mainstream media uh while we're getting
that number what she's doing right now
is giving herself a raise that's what
she's mostly focused on right now she's
giving herself a raise as Chicago is
purging people as people are being shot
left and right but she wants you to know
it's not a raise it's not a raise even
though her salaries if guys if I was to
increase your salary what would you call
it a uh raise right it's but when she
does it it's not a raise it's a cost of
living thing okay that's what it is when
it's hurt do we have some numbers on
Chicago murders and deaths we got
anything you're trying to you got to
carry the one it's a lot right it's a
lot we're getting something
60 people were shot in Chicago this past
weekend only five killed only five
killed pretty good Lori Lightfoot you
deserve a raise only five were killed in
your city this week anyway what the
other the other thing of course that
they'll do is they will always obfuscate
right they will confuse you about what
the real issues are and they will take
things that are nothing and make them
seem huge and then they will take huge
things and make them seem like they're
nothing
I got to show you the ladies of the view
do we have the yeah here we go it's the
harpies of the view they did their
Halloween show yesterday and look at the
way they abuse I mean this is child
abuse enjoy okay so one of the hugest
topics that you guys talked about this
year the raid on Trump's Mar-A-Lago
estate yes
[Applause]
so we have Trump as a toilet with our
FBI agents
[Applause]
foreign these people really are
disgusting like what kid like as if a
kid thought of that I get it it's all
theater it's a show okay fine it's just
gross the politicization of everything
with these people it's all they have
it's all they care about you know what
kids usually want to be at we were out
with the kids yesterday we were all
skeletons we were a skeleton family we
we were the Skeleton Crew that's what we
said we were the Skeleton Crew there
were a lot of skeletons out here
um but there were we saw some Batman we
saw some Supermans we saw some Star Wars
people we saw some witches uh Dracula
that sort of thing we didn't see any
Donald Trumps uh as toilets strange it's
strange that kids wouldn't be Mommy I
want to be the Mar-A-Lago raid
so what is it that voters actually care
about right now do they care about the
Mommy I want to be a mar-lago raid or do
they care
about crime and the economy and all of
that stuff well here is Republican New
Hampshire Governor Chris sununu taken it
to Chuck Todd on just that
why are you supporting an election
denialist and and do you think the
inflate inflation issue is enough uh to
comp to sort of rationalize support for
somebody who thinks
school buses of Voters are going to show
up in New Hampshire
yeah
yeah let me tell you you're in a bubble
man I love you Chuck but you are in a
bubble if you think anybody is talking
about what happened in 2020 or talking
about Mar-A-Lago and all that I know the
Press loves to talk about it people are
talking about what is happening in their
pocketbooks every single day look I
guess when they have to buy groceries or
right now
yeah overall
okay how could they
of course oh my gosh Chuck this is
hitting people they're having trouble
paying their mortgage they're in trouble
making car payments because of bad
policies out of Washington should they
be that is look the beauty of the
American system is every voter has the
right and almost the responsibility to
be selfish with their vote to vote in
terms of what is best for their family
the better choice for schools better
Economic Opportunity and that's exactly
what's going to happen in a week which
is why Hassan's going to get fired a
whole bunch of these Democrats are going
to get fired because frankly folks that
think that we're that the average voter
is worried about 2020 the average voter
it's a serious issue of course but it is
not what people are going to be voting
on in the next week and that's kind of
has baffled me through this whole
campaign season
so noon is pretty solid I I don't know a
ton about the guy but that's that's the
truth people don't care about this
election nonsense what we want are safe
and secure elections and we want
officials in charge that are going to
make sure that say you have to have an
ID that you can't double vote that we're
going to have secure elections when it
comes to mail and ballots and you can't
actually see through the envelope and
see who people voted for which is
exactly what we had in California when I
voted there last year but Chuck Todd I
mean he should just put just put on I
get it it's Meet the Press just put
under your name and Democrat operative
just put it on I like Democrats I'm
Chuck Todd I dig Democrat stuff and then
the show would feel a little bit more
honest right of course it would but but
this is this is what they're going to
keep running with and by the way after
the Red Wave next week one week from
today trust me you are going to be
allowed to question elections again and
trust me they will unleash violence on
the streets again when they feel it's
appropriate when they need to turn that
knob so you think about things a little
bit differently to rile up the face
again they're telling us already let's
not forget Hillary Clinton a few days
ago and then hit Chelsea Clinton on The
View two days ago what did she say she
has literally evidence that the
far-right mega Republicans are planning
on stealing the election it's odd she
didn't show the evidence why do I keep
printing out all this paper we have all
this paper here we're always printing
things Hillary didn't bring the paper
very odd uh what do Americans really
care about well there's a guy down in
here here in Florida who knows what's up
we also believe that and I and my wife
and I are sensitive to it just because
we have a five four and two year old at
home and you think about raising kids
now I I thought that it was ever easy
but when I was growing up there were
just way less things that like could
really be bad in front of kids it seemed
like now you know parents got to worry
about all these different influences and
we just believe that as a parent you
know you should have the the ability to
send your kid to school they should be
able to watch cartoons play with friends
just be kids without having some agenda
shoved down their throat
ain't it the truth ain't it the truth of
course it's the truth we want kids to be
able to be kids we don't want them
indoctrinated whether it's this gender
or sexuality stuff or this neo-racism or
to grow up hating their parents hating
their family hating the country and that
is why Florida is thriving that is why
every freaking day on MSNBC and on all
of these other shows they're constantly
attacking Florida because we are showing
them how it's done and it's done right
here and let me just say something else
about about Florida because I've
mentioned this before but it's not just
that we have a good governor and the
policies are right what happens after
good policy maybe it's a little bit of
chicken or the egg actually I think you
could probably argue it both ways but
what happens either after or before a
good policy I guess good people vote in
good policy so you can do it either way
but then the spirit of community starts
spreading I can tell you from being out
on the streets yesterday during
Halloween
it was there was so much joy there was
so much celebration so many people
saying hi to each other having a blast
smiling introducing each other uh
introducing people to each other we're
obviously new in town here we happen to
be a family with two dads oddly I didn't
get eggs or shaving creams or have
anyone scream at us or anything people
were thrilled to meet us and very happy
and it was just great and we met all the
neighbor kids and all that stuff that
was in stark contrast to what I would
see on Halloween in La where people are
afraid of each other well especially
during covid you know so so freedom
freedom is so fundamental to being a
human that once you have it you kind of
forget about it because you shouldn't
have to think about it all the time
because it's it's in it's within us
right but you have to elect people that
will help defend it that's what we've
done here and that's why the Democrats
are freaking out right now because they
don't care about Freedom they care about
power and that is a stark Stark
difference and what does that all lead
to well Joe Rogan who has a small I'm
told this is an internet web show and
some sort of podcast or something
he now has come around this is a guy who
was a Hollywood guy Californian fled
California moved to Texas uh definitely
not what you'd call a traditional
Republican as he's a mushroom meeting
MMA fighting Ayahuasca doing uh you know
muscle bound Meathead or something like
that uh well he knows that the red waves
are coming the Red Wave that's coming is
going to be like the elevator doors
opening up in The Shining
that's what I think I think people are
just like what the [ __ ] are you saying
they're making Republicans I don't know
how they're doing it it's I had a family
member who isn't who's a boomer and a
die-hard liberal and they told me when I
was home this Summer that they would
vote for DeSantis and I'm like how did
you lose this person yeah how did you
lose this person this is a this is a
like go to the ballot and vote blue no
matter what and you've lost even the the
Boomers
I love Bridget she's been on the show
many times she's she's a dear friend of
mine I know how they did it you know how
they did it they would not stop with the
woke stuff it's as simple as that the
Liberals would not defend liberalism
this is something I've been talking
about for a long time so all of the good
people the moderates The Joe Rogan types
the people who don't care about politics
that much finally first they look at
their wallets and they go none of this
makes sense right Elon Musk has to move
Tesla from California to Texas because
of tax purposes Rogan signs a 200
million dollar deal he's just looking at
the numbers and then he goes okay
Democrat run states have massive taxes
taxes has no income tax well that's one
part then you realize you don't want uh
your kids second grade teacher talking
to them about chopping their genitals
off that seems like a pretty much a
throwaway to me like we don't want that
so if you don't want that you'd be more
inclined to move to a red state if you
want your kids to be taught that America
is actually fundamentally decent and how
about we have an honest assessment of
what our founding is and what what our
history is well you could do that in
certain red States but it's getting
increasingly harder and harder to do in
blue States and in blue cities so you
might want to blow up the Department of
Education you might want to have less
centralized control you might realize
that say Randy Weingarten who's the head
of the teachers union is a Democrat
activist who for some reason was in
Ukraine two weeks ago there's a so much
weirdness here but it's all kind of
obvious if you've been paying attention
and I know you guys have and that's why
I hope Joe Rogan is right that that
scene in The Shining right and the blood
just rushes right in um
it's like that's what we need at the
moment and then we can get back to where
we started at the top of the show with a
bunch of kids running around New York
City and the cops are worried about too
much shaving cream because crime is
pretty low at that point right like we
can get back to something normal I know
we can because it's here where I live
right now and it's not just the policies
it's the people as well so that's that's
where we're at it's one week from today
people we'll be voting in person by the
way you guys you guys didn't do melons
right we're all going to go in person
we're okay we're all going to go in
person on Election Day so I'm gonna go
that morning and I will come and do the
show live uh right after that a couple
comments from the locals community and
then we got a cold close for you Amy
says I cannot wait for election day my
husband took the next day off work so we
can stay up late to watch the results
come in Across the Nation well that is
fantastic hopefully there won't be any
pipe bursts remember what happened on
Election night when Trump was running up
for re-election a pipe burst in
Philadelphia next thing you know five
states disappear off the map and blah
blah blah I don't want to get kicked off
YouTube today things have been pretty
good for us lately Chuck says Larry
Elder would severely limit the amount of
and types of attacks the left can use
without completely outing themselves as
complete racist Hypocrites well yes for
sure however
they're so deep in the mire and the muck
that they do it nonetheless right so
that's why the LA Times dared to write a
headline the black face of white
supremacy in the middle of his campaign
or how about when some crazy Democrat
lunatic put on a monkey costume and
threw something at him while he was in
Venice Beach and for some reason MSNBC
and CNN didn't pick that up right like
there is no depth because they only care
about power to the inconsistencies of
what they will talk about and won't talk
about and that's why we just gotta we
gotta be a little bit better we got to
vote in the right people and then and
then as I keep saying it sounds a little
corny but then we can look in that rear
view mirror and say AO see you later
enough of you people we're going to the
promised land now that's where we're
headed EK says that if that were
Democrats interrupting a republican
rally there would have been a lot of
more objects thrown in blood spill
possibly EK by the way who's a great
member of the community sent us this
awesome care package of homemade knitted
blankets and little bears and an
alligator for the for the boys and
they're they're loving it uh Luke
particularly we're wrapping him in that
blanket he's just loving it soft
whatever you use super soft thank you
for that DK uh guys if you have not
liked and subscribed on YouTube and
Rumble please go ahead and do that as I
just mentioned we just closed out
October we crushed it on YouTube by like
50 bigger or maybe it was even 60 bigger
than any other previous month in the
history of the channel Rumble is
absolutely blowing up I think the
message is getting across I think new
people are Finance I think the
algorithms are being a little bit nicer
to us I think some people found us
through the Bill Maher thing
um
it's all amorphous but if you always
want to stay directly in contact with me
reubenreport.locals is the best way and
that's where you're going to get the the
personal side of all of this madness I
leave you oh part one of my interview
with Senator Tom Cotton is up right now
on YouTube and Rumble to full things up
on locals already uh and we leave you
with the elderly man pretending to be
president uh at his little Halloween
party yesterday see you tomorrow
[Music]
happy Halloween
today
[Music]
thank you thank you
[Music]